welcome to inner world and meet robert
our unlikely hero
robert lives in asposia a world that
exists inside a huge hollow space deep
underneath our everyday world he's the
protagonist of our game and he's on a
quest to solve some riddles
the inner world is an adventure game
with a story that's rich in dialogue and
detail
it was created by studio fisbin a
developer based in ludwig
in the inner world we found a perfect
plan between a game for older
experienced adventure game lovers and
for a younger generation of players
that's why we won the best family game
award and we're very proud of it
they were still students when they got
their start two years ago programmer
alexander pieper art director marika
otrand
and game director sebastian mittag
three months ago mitthogg opened a
branch office of studio fispin in berlin
the three founders talk over skype
almost every day
as art director marika otran is
responsible for developing the
characters she draws them by hand the
asposians are supposed to be from
another galaxy but their personalities
and traits are very human
and good character a good character has
to be vulnerable in some way
a character has to resemble us in some
way if we're going to empathize with it
that doesn't really happen when the
character is a superhero who can do
everything
so that's always something we try to
bring to our characters
they aren't superheroes with amazing
superpowers
they're regular beings who just find
themselves dropped into a situation that
they have to deal with
it was their first big project three
years of work a staff of 20 and lots of
dedication went into it
alexander piper programmed the computer
and the mobile version
released a few months ago the mobile
version soon topped the sales charts for
several days at the apple app store
success is a great motivator
it's a great feeling for us as a small
studio to stand shoulder to shoulder
with the big studios that were also
nominated for the german developers
prize
edging our way onto the stage between
all the really big guys it's a great
feeling
guys and they're told
the young team was nominated for five
categories in this year's german
developers prize competing with some
established companies
like hamburg's data lake entertainment
whose goodbye deponia took first place
in the category best adventure game
it's worse than any of you the first
person shooter crisis iii by the
frankfurt based crytek company also
netted several awards
it has to offer a framework that
immerses the player in the game and
creates a flow
i achieve flow by creating a game that's
not too difficult but still challenging
enough to make it interesting
and this is where aspiring developers
can learn how to do just that the film
academy baden-wurttemberg in southern
germany
their interactive media program teaches
video game design and development it's
where the three fisben founders met and
came up with their award-winning idea
studio fisman began working on their
second game in october it ventures into
new territory a dark world inspired by
the american master of horror fantasy hp
lovecraft
once that society
drawing monsters is a lot of fun because
you can really go to town
you can add an eye here leave out the
upper jaw there
and you work with moods
you browse the internet find things you
like combine them try them out and in
the end you come up with a style
the new project will also be an
adventure game but aimed at adults
titled beyond the mountains it's slated
for release this spring